the United States Public Health Service
has had a major role in determining the
value of penicillin in the treatment of
venereal disease much of this work has
been done under the direction of dr. J R
Heller jr. more than 200,000 new
infections of syphilis are acquired in
this country each year all are actually
are potentially highly infectious if
these patients could be found in treated
before they have a chance to spread
their infections that would soon be a
marked reduction of sippers increased
alertness in diagnosis is important as a
first step in bringing this about early
diagnosis not only aids in reducing
syphilis but also is important in
improving the outlook for cure of the
individual patients one or more of these
cases - often unnoticed or unlooked-for
may be present in the physicians waiting
room physicians should examine the
genitalia the skin and the mucosa for
lesions of early syphilis they should
employ both dark field microscopic
examinations and blood serologic tests
look for such symptoms as early penile
lesions the lips Shanker
and the noticeable gamma
other manifestations are the sore throat
any mucosal lesions which do not heal in
10 days any unexplained loss of hair
general malaise loss of weight fever or
macular and maculopapular and group
follicular eruptions the clinician may
occasionally be surprised to find among
his patients long neglected cases such
as this example of advanced syphilis the
early latent stage often passes
unrecognized there are probably scores
of latent syphilis cases passing through
your office each year blood and spinal
fluid tests are the principal diagnostic
procedures available in the early latent
stage of syphilis this applies also to
the late latent stage with an increased
probability of positive spinal fluid
findings for example the colloidal gold
test for Paris appears in this manner
and is usually indicated by this type of
curve while the test for at abetik
reaction responds in this manner let us
look at some typical late manifestations
of syphilis inai Elysian aneurism
charcoals join
ocular nerve palsy and optic atrophy
syphilis of the central nervous system
Paras assort AV on the basis of present
evidence penicillin appears to have
great value in the treatment of syphilis
in virtually all stages and
manifestations this lesion which we saw
earlier has been treated with penicillin
treatment was on a schedule of 40,000
units every three hours which will total
2,400,000 units in 7 and 1/2 days the
healing of this lesion was accompanied
by a serologic reversal which occurred
over a five-week period we cannot always
expect such ideal results however the
more obstinate cases may require for
long therapy and attention zero logic
reversal may require many weeks or
months and in some rare cases even
clinical symptoms may recur no final
statement can be made at this time
regarding the place penicillin will
eventually occupy in the treatment of
syphilis these elements are occurring so
rapidly that it is not feasible to
recommend here precise dosages and
methods of administration but it is
important to keep abreast of progress in
the field your professional societies
and journals your health departments and
the United States Public Health Service
are all reliable sources of information
against gonorrhea the advent of
penicillin presents a strong and
efficient weapon here we can be more
definite in our suggestions under
penicillin therapy the gonorrhea patient
is completely ambulatory toxic reactions
are almost unknown discomfort and pain
are slight fortunately the gonococcus is
highly susceptible to penicillin and
control is apparent almost at once the
patient from whom this specimen was
taken received four intramuscular doses
of 50,000 units of penicillin and
aqueous solution at three hour intervals
total 200,000 units within 24 hours the
smears should be negative complications
such as epididymitis arthritis and
endocarditis require larger and prolong
dosage as an alternative procedure a
single dose of 300,000 units of
penicillin in oil and wax has proved
effective in gonorrhea with a minimum of
inconvenience to the patient warning the
maximum penicillin dosage for gonorrhea
may inhibit the normal development of
clinical and serologic symptoms of a
concomitant syphilis infection a blood
specimen for serologic testing should be
taken before therapy has begun each
gonorrhea patient should be strongly
urged to report for serologic and other
tests for syphilis at suitable intervals
for three to six months after completing
the treatment for gonorrhea whatever the
future may hold of penicillin therapy we
physicians already have in our hands
weapons which with proper medical usage
should enable us to reduce material aid
the amount of venereal disease in the
United States